play for you the video of the robbery
and the related 9-1-1 call
or medical emergency
yes it is a man just pulled a gun on me
okay where did this happen at
through seven at the Statue of the
Washington carries
and where are you at right now
[Music]
at approximately 5 35 PM the initial
caller called dispatch back and vice
Smith was at the car wash across the
street
when the dispatcher asked why he did not
pick up her return call the initial
caller said he was trying to avoid being
shot
the initial caller said Smith was
wearing a Halloween mask and was
threatening and pointed his gun at him
and other people
now we will play the audio of the
related 9-1-1 call
911
you sit in front of the that was on
Martin Luther King the court was in the
Martin Luther King Car Wash Okay Marina
officers when officers called you you
didn't answer what happened well I'm
sorry I had to get away with you I don't
want to get shot
I was trying to get out of today ma'am
please understand that all right that's
why I'm asking now I see white block his
penetrations
[Music]
yeah
my five pounds
where is he at right now
sundown in front of the uh
[Music]
what color is
so it's a dog called the gray black I
don't know
okay and what is he doing with that
good point and idiot and other people
talking about right now
yeah
right now man
and he's just walking around threatening
people
at approximately 5 39 PM dispatch
received another call from a caller at
the Kerry Mini Mart the second caller
said that Smith pulled a gun on
customers then he walked to the middle
of the street and was walking toward the
Justice Center
the second caller advised Smith was
wearing green shoes
and green socks
now we will play for you the audio of
the related 9-1-1 call
address
[Music]
1504
[Music]
America police to your address
1504 West Perry
okay I'm sorry go ahead
really
um we have a a word to carrying anymore
we have a guy out there that has a gun
and he scooted on a couple of customers
he's trying to whackled right now see
White Rock Hispanic or Asian he's black
everybody
he's wearing green socks green shoes a
white T-shirt and a Freddy Meyer green
socks and shoes yes
where's the gun right now
I believe you're not still in his pocket
but he's in the middle of the street on
you know the medium and in the middle
okay he's in the middle of the street
yeah